welcome to this video playing and so 25
and I would have bet that I've tried him
before but it seems I didn't let's see
okay we get a Queens gambit and I'm
going with my normal Bishop f4 line of
all I spirit that never really went for
Bishop g5 nowadays that's the main line
and the q GD ok c5 yeah I always played
that line I don't know it well I have to
admit it's been ages since I looked at
it 95 is what they normally do trading
off the power firm nights is some the
right choice there this is this kind of
position is a bit better for white it's
am quite comfortable isolated Queen porn
position um right if five or not i think
so i'm not quite sure 95 is quite often
the right idea here threatening knight
c6 bcbc bishop a 690 exhibition takes is
this is just nice white is controlling
and white is controlling the square in
front of the pond quite reliably okay 94
okay let's do this that's a good square
for this bishop
so he just not a seven hang some but do
you want to take this I don't know might
be five might be good right maybe ki can
just trade this Bishop here yeah it
makes a good impression I think we
should be aid I can take Bishop e7 and
this would trade the bishop or I don't
know he has to play some fairly
unnatural moves to not give it away like
there should be five or so so any reason
not to play this I don't see it you
might get the pawn back right like take
take we need five Queenie to it well
it's still pretty a pretty decent
position okay do I go queen bee one here
trying to trade you know why not o Queen
a one actually Quinn a oneness and i
right okay yes he has root a eight in
any case okay let's start with this it
has to go to d4 anyway now queen bee one
further for the Queen trade okay he does
not have to trade of course I can play
Queen a five or something but it doesn't
doesn't really help him much k rooks see
one
end game is nothing special child so
quite comfortable of course um I can
take their Quincy a dump but I'm
checkmated myself so only one there this
guide of calendar check has to be
reckoned with so he allows me to take
them ok let's prepare that
hmm and Queen you one down the cuckoo
know Quincy to ask anyone
what is he doing he and let's just try
that he moves the night I have Bishop g6
in most in most cases that something has
to think of at least 92 I don't know
that looks strange even Queen you one
isms then now night at 393 that's not
not so clear what is what he should play
cannot go early way I was just about to
say he cannot go fi but he did of course
yeah this looks very very weak on the
dark square so something that I I fail
to believe going to block him there and
if this move so now I'm completely
fixing him on the dark squares sorry I
mean Vic the pawns are faked on life fix
on light squares but what I want to say
is that i can try to exploit them and
weaknesses there on the dark squares
Noah Quincy aid is a threat Quincy eight
is a threat a thought or is he just
grabbing stuff that I don't I don't get
it now I have to enter if I can enter
here I should do that Queenie one is
really just a check okay you cannot take
me to a thought you cannot take it I
thought Queen here he in fact has Bishop
a seven that's no direct made it's very
close but it's no direct check made
check repair 796 chick check
don't see you in at the moment
absolutely not night g 5 95 years ago
bishop g8 I think I then Queen check
their check there I it looks terrible
advice the maid I don't see the need but
it still looks right okay of course the
move I did not expect I'm morning as
usual check in there check check
yeah no no I'm see no he's stepping into
it the salaries but still I don't see
how how are we to win check there's also
not mate check check
he has to go to has to go them Queen f6
again made threat but it seems that you
can award since it can always hold this
what if we had gained this is sometimes
night I have six chick check check yeah
he can move the king and it's nothing
can't believe or any of that but it
seems to be the case and you can check
you can probably play on time then check
check aim drawn Weiss is not winning and
come on this is not fair really you're
taking their with with Queen and night
does this is bad king and his it
snatches the pawn there why is this not
a witness is unbelievable he's dead on
the dark squares completely dead them
and there's no win her computer doesn't
find a chick made this is possible
unbelievable so I so I cannot play
Quincy 8 yeah this is really really
really funny I mean for a win of course
I want to win this position with this
kind of this kind of Swiss cheese thing
can't he just took it you can't a
channel made unbelievable czech even in
the quad the game has just made a
computer fun chatting they have it check
doesn't find chat isn't fine
wind now this is never check never a
window check yeah yeah this is just to
draw oh thats it's really tough I mean
f5 is really wow and black survives that
that's it's amazing that's amazing so I
shouldn't shouldn't give up the pawn
this is the essence of it all okay why
can I can't play slowly I simply
couldn't believe I can take the pawn it
looks really weird that you can but ok
me but it seems seems to be seems to be
the case it's a way not to give this
pawn up be three probably not sure this
is helping much maybe it's not enough
maybe it's not enough it looks really
bad but possible that is just a draw
well ok thanks for watching